we have a blockbuster new report uh out
of rolling stone
donald trump's lawyers increasingly
believe that mark meadows his own former
chief of staff is going down legally and
it seems as though they may be getting
closer and closer to abandoning meadows
now there's a parallel story here to
this which is that yesterday i played
for you video
from the january 6 committee
wherein liz cheney says we are now aware
of donald trump personally calling a
forthcoming witness someone who has not
yet testified
and trying to tamper with the witness
trying to influence or in some way
affect their potentially forthcoming
testimony we don't know who that person
is but there's rampant speculation that
it's mark meadows and parallel to that
there is now this incredible story from
the from rolling stone that trump's
lawyers think meadows is going down and
the question now is how to minimize
the uh sort of secondary damage the
shrapnel with which others may be hit if
indeed mark meadows testifies and goes
down rolling stone writing exclusive
trump's lawyers think mark meadows is
going down the january 6 committee is
probing the former chief of staff's
finances rolling stone has learned
adding to a long list of legal headaches
as she opened the january 6 committee on
tuesday liz cheney ticked through a list
of names of people trump's legal team
have attempted to pin the blame for the
capital attack naming the president's
lawyers maga friendly lawmakers and
others mark meadows didn't make the list
yet but trump's inner circle
increasingly views meadows as a likely
fall guy for the former president's
attempt to overturn the 2020 election
members of trump's legal team are
actively planning certain strategies
around meadows downfall including
possible criminal charges trump has
himself begun the process of distancing
from some of his one-time senior aides
alleged actions around january 6. this
is the new part meadows already bleak
legal prospects could get even worse
because rolling stone has learned that
the january 6 committee has been quietly
probing his financial dealings and any
new revelations would add to an already
long list of unethical and potentially
illegal actions he's accused of taking
on behalf of donald trump quote everyone
is strategizing around the likelihood
that mark is in a lot of trouble says a
lawyer close to the former president
everyone who knows what they're doing
anyway rolling stone spoke to eight
sources familiar with the matter
everyone's still in trump's orbit or on
his legal defense or in republican
circles in contact with trump
everybody's speaking
candidly because they were provided
anonymity so there's a few interesting
components to this
first of all it would not be unlike
donald trump to run a multi-pronged
strategy publicly distance from the
people that might be going down
and privately try to influence them in
order for them to damage you less and
it's completely speculative but there's
the question was the phone call that
trump made to try to tamper with a
witness uh to mark meadows the other
part of this
is that meadows is actually the the
financial questions around meadows and
the voting questions have been going on
for a while if i recall correctly
there's sort of two avenues to this and
it's sort of strange that everybody
around trump has these problems mark
meadows had one issue
related to voter registration uh i'm i'm
kind of giving you the 30 000 foot view
but apparently meadows
owns a trailer somewhere
that he has never even been to
and was registered to vote at that
address which is weird and also
registered to vote elsewhere so that was
one thing we talked about maybe six
eight nine months ago something like
that
and then again if i'm going for memory i
believe that on the financial side
there's something tax related to mark
meadows and it also may relate to what
state do you
formally live in or whatever the case
may be
so if and how that connects directly to
trump is a question but anything that
puts him more on the radar of
investigators is potentially bad for
donald trump so as far as the witnesses
there's a january 6th hearing
sometime next week i don't even know
that it's been scheduled specifically
yet
and we don't know who the witness is
going to be who the witnesses
potentially are going to be we've been
told it's going to be absolutely
stunning could it be meadows
uh could it be steve bannon i don't know
but it could be maybe the most
interesting day of the hearings
altogether liz cheney made clear this is
a witness you have not yet seen
and um that there's a long list of
people that could fall into that
category but we will soon know and if
meadows goes down i mean remember
the the strategy from these people trump
etc has been whenever anyone gets in
trouble minimize their role minimize
their role in the trump campaign or the
administration or in whatever
it's going to be
impossible to minimize the role
of the last and final chief of staff
that donald trump had
who was
personally doing the bidding of trump in
the lead-up to the january six riots i
mean they'll try of course they'll try
but it's not going to be i think
even the average american as we like to
say is going to see through that let me
know your thoughts who do you expect to
be the blockbuster witness coming up
next week you can find me on twitter at
dpakman and we'll be covering it of
course
many of us know what it's like to have
acne show up when we least want it to
you should have seen me in middle school
now i'm on camera and i really do the
best i can to keep my skin clear and for
that i go to apostrophe our sponsor on
the apostrophe website you just answer a
few questions take a couple pictures of
your skin and then you have a virtual
visit with a board-certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan they quickly
ship you the prescription medication i
can tell you that when it comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me
apostrophe makes it simple and quick
i've had a great experience with
apostrophe myself you get affordable
quality medical treatment from a
licensed dermatologist and prescription
meds that actually work but i can do it
all on my phone i don't have to spend
hours in a doctor's office
my audience gets 15 off your first
dermatology visit go to apostrophe.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description